we're back to talking about Thomas
Aquinas and instead of talking about
question number two of the first part of
this first part this one is all about
God we're now in the second part we're
in the first part of the second part of
the Summa Theologica
and that is about human beings and so
we're going to look at a topic that we
discussed before what's happiness and
remember we've talked about this with
Aristotle at the beginning of the nikah
mckay and ethics plato was concerned
about this to make people happy Judas
was also concerned with this question
what what will actually make you get the
traffic to units that had to do with
freeing yourself from thanks so we've
already seen a number of different
answers to this question what makes you
happy how do you tell what makes people
happy but some of you are going into
things like fashion or business those of
you who figured out what your major is
some of you are going into criminal
justice you probably actually are
interested in the opposite what makes
people unhappy because we punish people
we make them unhappy right so how do you
tell in your ordinary life what makes
people happy
could you do it you figured out what
makes you have any more or less and you
also to deal with other people
yeah if you want to get them to see
things your wedding right
I didn't tell what makes people happy
you're just have followed me around say
you're gonna shadow me for a day watch
me like say an anthropologist fine how
are you figure out what makes me tick no
jobs are the things that you do like
what you do a lot because you wouldn't
do it if you didn't enjoy it well yeah
what certain things I'm happy to do but
yeah I mean I've done a lot of things in
my life just for money you know that I
wasn't particularly keen on
unfortunately a lot of us have to work
jobs like that
I don't know thank God but I've worked
many a job I wasn't particularly fond of
but you're right yeah you could follow
somebody around and see what they do in
their work time and also in their spare
time if it turns out that you see me
collecting stamps messing around books
what else could you do that would be
like a routine right observe somebody's
routine so you look at what they do what
is what they do tell you about
yeah maybe I could tell you give you a
little bit of like what kind of a person
they are okay
like for instance let me give you a
scenario you follow along with me and I
go to a restaurant yeah what's always
have a restaurant no food no restaurant
right without some waiters and
waitresses yeah now notice I may have
asked you this before how many of you
have ever worked in a restaurant maybe
just a few of you they've all eaten in
restaurants you all observe people in
restaurants how do people treat survey
staff waiters and waitresses or
hostesses
what's the range
okay yeah
that's a good way to put it sometimes
people are respectful and they treat
them as a person sometimes they they
just don't care sometimes they can't
award it over though you know I'm paying
your salaries you'd better do whatever I
say you know who actually gives the best
tips who would you guess gives the best
tips
just take a guess
it's not millionaires rich rich people
often don't get very good tips that's
how they kind of stretch in first place
well think about it this way who do you
think can relate to the server or the
boss areas or the cooks what do you
think can relate to them the best yeah
oh yes so you've got other working-class
people
yeah not all the other working-class
people with other people in the industry
they tend to be the best tippers and it
works that way in most thing they can
relate to them they understand to go
back to the scantiness thing that part
of what makes us can be is being treated
like we matter being treated like we're
going to talk about power in a few
minutes and one of the easiest ways that
you can have power in this society is
walk into a restaurant you know if you
want to learn it over somebody and treat
somebody like garbage a lot of people do
that why do they do that they think that
that's that's good you can tell the
people desire what people value by
watching what they do what they pursue
what they what about when you have to
make a choice I can do this I'll have
this good or I'll do this and I like
this good let's say well the goods are
the same kind let's say you're lucky
enough to have two people interested and
attracted to you at the same time right
so you pick which one you want how do
you decide where to pick you just get
out of paradise
characteristics somebody one of them
let's say it's really good I kind of
mean to people the other ones not so
good-looking but a lot better than a
person which do you pick I mean it's
really easy to say well of course we
took the one who's got the big
personality but people get into these
quandary and if they have a very
difficult time choosing in part because
they haven't figured out what makes them
happy yet some people think that you
know if they just get together looking
they will be happy you know and it would
be very unusual for people your age
sometimes David for a lot of people my
age to have it all figured out what it's
going to make them happy sometimes it
takes you 60 years to figure out what
actually makes me happy but it's worth
thinking about so the visible part of
what we do in philosophy classes and
this is part of what Thomas's is doing
and if we're gonna do like a little
exercise thinking about your education
why are you here
what's the whole purpose of this and
whether it makes you happy or not but
before then let's think about what makes
people happy
in general and think about happiness in
the full sense I mean where have you
ever seen people truly happy think about
that for a minute have you seen people
not just you know say happy for a moment
but truly happening in a state that
lasts and flows throughout their entire
life and you might say even overflows
them it helps to make the people around
them happy how many of you seem game
did you see them in real life or is this
something you saw in a movie or TV show
or maybe you read about it I mean people
like that do exist happiness like that
does exist but it's not that common in
our society and there's a whole
literature about happiness so you know
why what can make us happy that that's a
fundamental question and when we ask
that you know it's really easy to come
up Wow you know getting an A in the
class that'll make me happy or making it
to Thanksgiving seeing my family if
you're sick you may have a very short
horizon I'll be happy if I can to make
it through the class and get to bed and
take it easy you happy when I'm no
longer said if you're a dad I'll be
happy when I'm no longer in debt if I
just get with this person I'll be happy
if I could just get this thing yeah
there's a lot of answers but we want to
ask because what make us really truly
happy not kind of happy I mean there's a
lot of things that can make you kind of
be happy if I bring doughnuts to class
I'll make you guys happy right I might
do that but that's not making you happy
the fundamental sense right well you're
gonna you know it's gonna overflow all
your life and make other people around
you happy and if it did then we should
all invest in Dunkin Donuts because the
answer to our questions you know a lot
of things we must wanting more
like what are what are some snacks that
make you happy I get thinking you know
probably too many snacks what do you
guys like to eat when you're watching TV
chips okay and chips now it is come in
like a million different flavors and you
can get kettle chips you can get them
organic they don't even have to be made
of potatoes anymore and now you can get
a medium sweet potatoes or all these
different types of things and so you eat
the whole bag of chips i Nev you ever
done that when you're probably not too
happy
well you might feel sick afterwards so
that that there could be consequences
like that but you you know you feel full
and you enjoy the taste I hope you know
you enjoyed the taste otherwise we're
just doing something quite futile but
doesn't really affect them you know the
rest of your life it's not like you can
eat your way to happiness it'll easily
wanting more not necessarily more chips
but more of other things it doesn't
fulfill you it doesn't as we say satisfy
it doesn't satisfy desire some things
leave you happy for a time right
think about romances people get involved
with another person and the first like
couple of weeks is they're walking on
air are they always that infatuated or
happy a lot of times this becomes like a
bone of contention marriages or
relationships people say you
- you used to be so happy with me now
you're not happy anymore
and that makes me unhappy well that's
because some things aren't actually made
to last like that
infatuation the sexual attraction and
that whole sense of romantic log may not
actually have a shelf life that's that's
that one
that's you know that's bad news or you
know some things can make you happy in
some respect but not really make you
happy overall it's interesting how many
of you would like to win the lottery are
there any people wouldn't like to win
the lottery
nobody so we all have you know fairly
well-defined feelings about this what
would you guys do how many of you would
invest it wisely now that you mention it
right yeah
how many of you would also you know do a
spending spree
yeah I'm just spending spree but not so
much that I would lose them I knew a guy
when I was working a security job and
we'll walk the third shift security job
and so I go drinking at these these
third shift bars afterwards
we can get a drink at 7:00 in the
morning because your whole schedule is
now screwed up because you're working
third shift yeah those are the bars
where you see the people who are
hardcore drinkers you know that's there
and there was a good thing in there
could have on the lottery and he was a
street person now he actually still had
he didn't
some people win the lottery they just
you know waste all the money with it
like a year two years they say this guy
didn't do that he had his money in the
bank and yet what he liked to do was to
live on the streets because you've done
it for so long that he'd gotten used to
it and that was his way of life so when
he won the lottery it didn't radically
change his way of life other than now he
could find drinks for everybody that's
how I got to know him because my buddy
who went to this bar all the time I only
let you know once in a while my buddy
was friends with this guy cuz he'd buy
drinks all the time and of course he had
all these these kind of you know street
people women hanging around - this guy
was probably about 60 you know was he
happy well in service packs I think he
was he always had you know money in his
pocket his life wasn't basically about
drinking and hanging around with with
what we call bar flies
shouldn't pool does that be happy in the
full sense what do you think did any of
you hear that story and say that's for
me that's the life I want or ever think
about it if you're if your brother or
sister said that to you your parents you
know as they getting older they say you
know know that you're out of the house I
think what I'd really like to do is just
hang around in bars and drink and then
you know live in a cardboard box what
would your reaction be when something's
gone wrong with marvered Yeah right
something's not working right be say
that because you think that they are
latching onto some sort of lesser idea
of happiness than they were previously
and you'd be worried about the future
let's think about what makes you happy
what does what makes you happy right now
to be simple things
yeah okay what does it about them that
makes you happy
this can go for anything because I'm
guessing the home Stallard you would say
family that's right what makes me happy
what if they're jerks they don't make
you happy to do that when they act like
jerks occasionally you just enjoy being
with them I mean it's not like you just
get home over Thanksgiving there's a
bunch of couches do this more often you
know you may actually spend a good
portion but notice if you're watching
the ballgame you're watching the
ballgame together right if you're eating
turkey together and all the other things
you're eating turkey together do you
have family traditions where one of you
makes a pumpkin pie and somebody else
makes the cranberry whatever it is
somebody else makes the stuffing you
have a family tradition you have
something substantive that that is going
on it's something that you share with
each other so there's kind of just
spinning tonight but also sharing good
one of the other goods that make you
happy
I could ask you something like what do
you like to eat that every one of you
couldn't tell me something all right you
like to eat right is there any anyone in
here who doesn't like to eat if I'm in
the act of putting things in their mouth
you know chewing them and tasting them
disgusting I don't want to have anything
to do with it there are some people who
have like a neurological problem at
first you know what we call these
cutters right what else do you find
pleasant yeah yeah exercise I mean I
don't find exercise pleasant anymore but
I remember what it was like when I was
in shape to find exercise Pleasant and
I'd like to get myself to the point
where I find it Pleasant again you know
I'm the only way I'll do that is by
doing the exercise at all don't like to
do now but yeah you know running for
those who are good at running people
play all sorts of physical games
together you know pickup pickup
basketball pickup football pick-up
hockey my daughter dances and then she
does it all the time whether she's in
dance class or not because she enjoys it
and she's good at so activity what are
other kinds of pleasures pleasures what
other kinds of pleasures enjoy
what are you doing your spare time on
your data classes besides work I know
some of you have jobs too yeah
sleeping is enjoyable it's a pleasure if
you're like most students were probably
actually a little sleep deprived most of
us you know middle-aged adults are
chronically sleep-deprived too because
where this worker nation right now what
else sleep most you take pleasure
there's all sorts of things imagine
right being their relationship yeah
they're you know sometimes we want to be
with family or friends or what do you
want to call them partners right a big
category because we enjoy their company
if you're in a relationship with
somebody in there they're no fun why are
you their relationship with them that's
a legitimate question sometimes people
want to guilt you into staying but if
you're not enjoying it
you know from a philosophical angle you
could answer what's the I imagine most
of you listen to music right watch TV
watch movies well the pleasures that's
Pleasant stuff to do what are other
activities yeah probably you do the part
not just because you like to shoot all
the time by yourself but it probably
also has any aspect of sometimes you get
to meet people by playing games with
them other activities
gonna be like working on cars anything
else mechanical renovating houses you
don't work on cars that's good
my fiance is actually Kira had she
fought when she was 16 that she was
gonna get a fancy car and instead she
was given a kind of a rundown car that
she had to do a lot of work on and she
found she actually enjoyed doing that
there's a lot of things where we don't
know we enjoy that we don't know that
they're part of what makes us happy
until we get thrown into them okay so
this is all we're where we are now where
are you going
you're you're here at MERIS hard to get
an education is that gonna make you
happy yeah someday it will lead to being
happy okay good job good job that's
that's pretty critical especially for us
Americans we we tend to identify who we
are with what we do much more than
people in other countries you know one
of the first things that you ask
somebody after you learn their name that
you know someplace where you're meeting
somebody on the train at a convention is
what's your line of work what is it that
you do because we do invest ourselves
and yeah presumably going to here to
embarrassed is gonna help you do that
right if you make the right choices to
cut grades to an internship all that
sort of stuff you guys are at the front
end of that but you you know you've seen
other people do is there anything else
that you're doing their merits that you
think has been to conduce to
to your happiness or as a purely
vocational I mean if it wasn't that
would be okay I have nothing against
people going to college because they
want to go to a job some people some
professors kind of look down on that
I come from you know the lower middle
class so I understand it playing a sport
okay that's something one way unless of
course you're thinking that you're going
to college sports and then transition to
the minor leagues with the major leagues
right does that happen here in theirs I
mean this is Division one so I think
actually maybe I should put this over
over here right that would probably for
those who like to play sports fall under
the category of good job to win them
what else what else is going on here
though you think is gonna make you happy
yeah making it friends yeah that's
making friends of a different sort and
then you had when you were in high
school right one of the great things
about college is you get to find
yourself which which really means that
you get to redefine yourself you get to
decide who you're going to be a part of
that will be your major moment you'll
start taking classes with I mean later
you're in this class with I imagine I've
asked you this before not too many of
you know each other that well but you're
gonna see each other at some of the same
classes over the next four years some of
you are going to get to know each other
very well I've become close friends and
you'll hold on to that after college you
you know you'd never have imagined that
next to them what else you know there's
there's another thing that happens in
college that we know sociologically
probably about half of you are going to
meet your potential mate either here at
Marist or where you go to graduate
school or were you in the board game we
if we put it to where you end up working
then it goes way way up because the two
places that we we tend to meet the
people that we're going to be involved
with long term whether you're going to
be happy or unhappy what do you think
but it has a lot to do to pick the wrong
person you're going to be miserable pick
the right person you're probably going
to be happy pick the right person and
then break up with them to go out with
somebody who's not the right person
you're you're ready probably going to be
miserable so that's kind of important
relationships anything else these are
all sort of like end points what are you
spending your time doing here at bears
couldn't you find a good job or sport to
play or people hang out with or somebody
to be with without going to college
why does your couch what's that not as
good though not as much just fall any
job and that's not the quality sport
yeah
notice what happen what happens with
that college becomes just a location
where these
things happen order provides a means how
many of you over the course of this
semester this is part of what I had to
do and then assignment where you I want
you to think about what you're gonna
write on how many of you have found at
least one philosopher over the course of
the semester that you feel you've got
something out that you liked reading and
you can see after the course is done
your hands may start going down down
after the course is done you'd like to
go back and read some more few minutes
got too many though what about what's
going on in your other classes are you
finding things that you like thinking
about am I talking about that you want
to research I hope all of you are if
you're not they find out the classes
because what's the point of college it's
not just to get you a job which is a
good thing but it's to find your mate or
make a lot of friends what's what why do
we have that library over there if it
was we could do all this stuff we
wouldn't need that library right well
once was in that library then I see some
of you in myself go to the library so
with you hanging out there at nine
o'clock at night which should be forever
I've never taught in a place where
students like to be in the library why
do you go there
yeah just out here you some work yeah
knowledge or you know certain share of
wisdom that you're required after
college I mean you I don't imagine any
of you are envisioning yourself as
philosophy majors right now and if I say
to you you're cultivating wisdom here in
that MERIS ecology way you might say
then that's silly I'm just studying this
or that I'm just studying this this this
major that major that doesn't make any
difference
wisdom but actually it does everything
that you're going to study the further
along that you get in it the more you
start asking the fundamental questions
that's wisdom and that is what makes
some people happy you saw this when we
talked about Aristotle now let's look at
with Thomas Aquinas says we've thought
about you know just the nature of you
happiness and what's going on with your
own education maybe some of these puzzle
pieces start to come together Thomas
looks at things ultimately from a
religious point of view so you can
imagine what what is he going to say
happiness ultimately sometimes when I
you know do this listing of what makes
you happy
yeah I mean if you have a religious
point of view you can be a philosopher
and be religious but if you are going to
do then
God had better fit in there somewhere or
otherwise you're not really religious
are you for Thomas Aquinas it's going to
be the ultimate source of happiness
let's think of this out a little bit so
if God is the ultimate source of
happiness that could be true in a very
trivial way if you believe that God
created anything and things make you
happy then God created the things that
make you happy
right so as you you like eating filet
mignon God made that filet mignon but he
made the whole universe and that filet
mignon was a part of that you know
moving together certain parts of the
universe taking a cow and cutting out a
certain part of it and applying fire to
it in certain ways and serving on a
platter so God could be the source of it
right
you'd be the source of that good are you
enjoying God didn't that baseball but
you know all the stuff that goes into if
you're if you're taking this religious
point of view God would have created not
directly but indirectly
cluding grab including the laws of
physics
so maybe God created all these things
and among these are some of the things
that make us happy this is what you call
needed and what's created being
everything that isn't God all right man
yeah you know if you think about the
traditional video Christian or Muslim
point of view there was a point in time
where God
let there be light there was a flight
before them and now there's life they
like to be created or all these animals
and stuff like that you think you know
you can work in evolution at that if you
want to tie those together you can say
God work through revolution we don't
want to get tied down with nitty gritty
we want to think about this in terms of
creative being and so what about
creative beings we're good among them
you guys talked about it's good to eat
right if you don't eat what happens yeah
and then you no way to it is not very
fun either
I mean how many of you have gone like a
day with them what's that sounds
terrible
yeah well it's it's no it's not a lot of
fun what happens yeah well you're hungry
all day
that's don't feel one oh yeah no energy
your stomach actually starts to hurt and
then no imagine doing this day after day
after day after a while you're going to
waste away food is a good thing it's a
good what a soul body right keeps your
body alive Thomas divides things the
creative goods into what he calls
external goods goods in the body and now
again he believes we have Sol Sol Sol
and what are some examples of external
goods well it tells you about wealth so
for example this is an external good
it's not part of my body right it's not
something that's my
say ministering or taking care of my
body it's a possession what else
well wealth of different sorts right
like oh I don't have any cash on me but
I have you know this will work even
better right because you can keep track
of things but this is external this is
not part of my body it's not part of my
soul it's something that I use to get
myself whoever the things that are
needful right what else
well I'm sure that you've all got some
of these right Thomas actually talks
about vehicles vehicles are good things
but they're not part of your body or
part of your soul they're external and
so if I you know throw these to mr.
Davis know if I wanted to you can have
my car right old Taurus wagon hip or
trendy thing to drive her out you
wouldn't go yeah but it's a good right
if I don't have my car I'm a bit unhappy
if I don't have anything in here if I
suddenly find myself with no credit
cards and no cash I'd say no ID I would
feel panicked because these are goods
these are good things the few times that
I've left my phone behind
have you ever go through that you
realize this is the only place that I
actually have my contacts I've got like
you know 50 people's numbers in here
that I don't I don't know
who's this if I drop this in the bathtub
or something
sick I'm really in trouble I better
write those numbers down but those are
all external can those things make you
truly happy they're good for something
all right
what does this good for me yeah
communication you know like a whole
bunch of different ways that's what
makes it a smart phone so I can be my
email on here can't do my Baris mail I
can get my Maris mail but I can't send
it but you can do a lot of things I can
surf the web with this what can I do
with the stuff that's in here buy things
right what can I do with the thing this
starts move from place to place these
are all useful things those are all
possessions those can make you happy in
a sense but they're not what happiness
truly is let's think about some other
things that are external thing some
people want to be famous right why do
they want to be famous they think it
will make them happy this is why people
are envious when other people are famous
they think that they're missing out on
something so you you know your friend
gets recognized or something that you
don't and you're the one who did it
they're taking your glory you're feeling
like you're missing out on some good but
if you get it is that really going to
make you happy might make you feel happy
for a while
but Fame is kind of fleeting isn't it
and it's dependent if you end up being
famous there's really two main reasons
one is you did something good if you did
something bad and you're famous for it
that's not really being happy isn't like
that malaria just went away for
manslaughter for Michael Jackson
probably not a happy guy but if you do
something really good then you become
famous for that I'd anything any of you
want to become famous for something yeah
like to be on the TV to be a sports
broadcaster okay and why would they hire
you because you'd do it well right and
after a while you acquire a reputation
when I get invited to talk I get invited
to talk basically but that's something
good the fame itself is not the good
thing it's what you're famous for though
so famous stealth can't be happiness
what about power now we're getting to
something more substantive yeah
and that's exactly what Thomas says he
says you know power whether it's good or
bad really depends on what you do it so
I mean there's all sorts of bad things
statement that power rots
why would power corrupt people didn't do
what you want
yeah but why would that mean that you
would do bad things you want to keep if
you're not completely good somebody
giving you power so power can't be
happiness could be a component of
happiness wealth could be something that
leads to happiness Thomas isn't saying
these things are no good he's just
saying they're not ultimately the main
thing what about if we get the things
that are more personal things that
really have to like think about goods at
the bottom what what are things that are
good for the body or they're good in the
body what makes a body can I have your
help none of you will give me your
health what if you know you don't like
the collection each one of you to give
me a little bit of your health and then
I'll be much more healthy Lyme's disease
now I found out that's not good either
you know it's health the sort of thing
where we can do that there's actually a
movie oh yeah what's that called it's
got a bunch of famous stars and it looks
to be pretty interesting but it's
science fiction because you can't do
that sort of that can you
you can't take some of your health and
give it to something else
I mean you could do it maybe with an
organ transplant but good for the body
health is important well strength would
an idiot like to be stronger than you
are physically we have more endurance we
have more agility grace that's a huge
industry not only to be good-looking but
to be good smelling good feeling yeah
well these are all bodily goods and
these are all good things are they what
happiness consistent I mean some people
think they are the person who spends all
their time at the gym and exfoliating
and cleansing and all that sort of stuff
and they have no time left
for anything else clearly they think
that that's going to make them happy
there are some people who do that but if
we if we consist of body and soul could
anything that just focuses on the body
make us truly happy would be satisfying
the part of us dogs are you happy with
things of the body we have two dogs and
one of them dogs will eat until they're
like they don't have that sort of shut
off thing that we do and we left the
food thing open and one of the dogs ate
like pounds of dogs just like you know
we have these big containers and you
could see like you know it was like this
much before and it was like that'll be
here you know well you know that's cuz
that's happiness for her daughter that's
that's as good as it gets that may be
chasing things and curling people those
are all physical goods
what about goods are the solar what
makes your soul good we talked a lot
about this over the semester doing the
right thing like feeling good about
yourself and what you doing yeah being
able to feel good about yourself not
good for your constant lying to yourself
or you know saying I'm good because I
push this person down and make them look
of it because you actually do good
things and if you're the kind of person
who does good things what do we call you
that's good or nice sort of the v good
quality is on our virtues right virtues
are something that you actually possess
if you're actually courageous that's not
something that you had yesterday you
know me up now and it sticks with you or
if you're just if you do the right thing
at the right time
dividing things up the intere with
people that's something that sticks with
you that because it's part of your your
sole part of your personality it's part
of who you are and you know Aristotle
thought that happiness did consist in
that didn't me and Plato who seem to
think that happiness Thomas says that
could be part of the happiness and the
soul is actually what we experience
happiness through in fact the new habit
souls what allows you to experience
happiness but ultimately these are just
parts of a larger thing once you put God
in the picture God has been a you know
dwarfed anything else we saw this with
the enzone right if you if you have
something like that damage nothing
greater can and can be thought
can you put anything else next to it and
compare it effectively what about you
know like the best meal you've ever had
probably had some really good meals
right I'll put that next to God infinite
creator the universe perfectly good know
where of everything that really great
meal starts to seem kind of pale in
comparison even even though the best
relationship to God we're working with
the traditional concept he would seem to
pale in comparison Thomas says any
created good is not going to truly
satisfy us now here's where it gets
really interesting and this is where we
actually go a little bit beyond Thomas's
texts I had a conversation with I guess
you would call my cousin
to be right somebody who is from my
fiance's family and even this guy's a
theologian and he was talking about
let's say we actually get to this stage
and we say yeah God has got to be in the
picture somehow not just all these other
creative units
how do people then approach that if you
actually he's approaching it as a
theologian not as a philosopher like I
am so what he points out is that if you
look at these world religions and he's
looking at - even a Bible in particular
what do you see over and over again you
see that people who are religious will
know on some level that God is the
ultimate right and happiness itself but
where do they place all their efforts
where do they place their enjoyment
in the good things which they take to be
provided by God some way right so if you
if you think about the goodness of God
if we want to use that term goodness
there's the goodness of God he has what
God is and then there's the goodness of
God as in God like giving you nice
things lots of things right so if you
believe that your you have your life
because God made you live that's a good
thing right or if let's say your the
Israelites out of the desert and you
know manic comes down from heaven and
you know you get Quayle every once in a
while it's basically the story right and
so you've got good food and you didn't
die on the desert and you believe that
God gave it to you well you could say
he's a really swell guy he treats us
really nice but you know we're not
really interested in who he is for what
he is we're interested of what he gives
us life happiness this way in that way
so there's this constant tension Thomas
is saying that what's going to make us
truly happy is not just all the things
that we get but God had God Himself God
itself
trinitarian christian now if you say it
like that it sounds kind of sterile
doesn't it sounds kind of strange to me
well all these other things are going to
make it truly happy only God knows what
anyone has got let's think for a bit
about our ideas of gap what do people
typically say if you ask them I don't
know what this god thing is that you're
talking about what do they say
besides to read the Bible because that's
not much of an answer all right that's
just putting it off go find the answer
yourself let's say you generally have
somebody who is perplexed and so what
about this guy business what'd you say
yeah okay so we would talk about these
metaphysical attributes supreme meaning
above everything else supreme in what
ways supremely cool couldn't be that
guess I don't know cool it's kind of a
human thing the various replace the
place supremely good I guess I'm
supremely wise when I was when I was a
math major I used to think of God as the
being that knew the answers to all the
problems that we couldn't figure out
kind of nice to talk to something like
that because then you'd know the answers
why they are the way they are but that
really you know that's you're gonna only
see that as a good thing if you're
really into answers right you don't care
about that sort of thing this is a tough
one you know if you say that that God is
happiness itself that God is what we
would have to seek in order to truly be
happy
those metaphysical attributes are
important I would like to be in touch
with whatever it's supremely good
whatever supremely wise but do you think
that's enough
will that make you happy
they get anything more would be required
Thomas is not telling us he doesn't know
their good parts of the Sun but I want
us to sort of think this out what would
it take in order to find your happiness
and God rather than all these other
great things maybe it would be you know
you could just be disgusted with
everything right try everything out I
mean if you ever read the book of
ecclesiastes worth reading if you think
that the Bible is just a you know
certainly happy skip along everything's
great can a Pollyanna kind of document
it isn't I mean the book of Ecclesiastes
is a philosopher who's saying nearly
everything is when you get down to it
crap and I know because I've actually
tried it all out and I found that that
this was great for a while and then it
went to crap and this was - that went to
crap when I was the king for a while and
that wasn't so hot and what did you know
if you look at the world you notice that
good people are getting getting it in
the neck and bad people are prospering
and that doesn't seem too hot to give
there that's in the Bible that's one of
the the certain perspectives that's
that's put across so you know maybe you
could get to God by saying oh yeah
everything else is such a disappointment
let me try this
what do you come if you don't know what
God is and how can you find God I don't
get it like you said we relate to God
what he's giving off so if we can't
determine ourselves what God is
for us how can you know what to seek if
look if God does exist and God gave us
all these things yes that's what we need
to God well I mean are there other ways
to relate or that other people talked
about what do people do some of them are
headed yeah some of them are what you
want right because they though they say
that gods are really important part of
life their life but they spend most of
time criticizing everybody else that's
not a big tournament is it well what do
people who you can actually respect who
claim that God is an important part of
life what do they do that's different
than other people anything if they don't
then maybe to just take out of the
picture what would do
some of them do some of them yeah they
do what we call in the Angela and they
they not only want them to believe they
want you to believe too but a lot of
adults I've known a lot of religious
people who don't try to evangelize they
do other things yeah if somebody's like
securing their belief of God then why
they need to prove to other people are
gotta do this oh look at this
let's go off that's kind of a digression
and we'll come right back to there's the
answer yeah yeah if I've had a really
good experience and I care about you I
would want to share it with you and
that's some people seem to want to
evangelize because they want to believe
like that and other people seem to
actually want to communicate some some
good the day they experienced it
sometimes it's difficult to tell the
difference to until you get to know the
person but what again what else do
religious people do that's different
how do they end up having that sort of
experience where they enjoy something
that they say I couldn't get this
there's no one single answer by the way
we know this by looking at there was
just people some of them pray I mean I
myself I have a hard time imagining I
don't have a hard time sort of
sympathizing with but imagining what
somebody does he prays for a couple
hours a day what they could possibly
talk about that because I know I can't
you know think of much to talk about
myself but I think about some supreme
being that I would connect myself but
that's probably a problem on my mark
right that's a failure that's I think
what else do they do some religious
people don't pray much at all mother
Teresa you know said she had a very
barren prayer life and yet she was this
great religious leader she went around
certain people took care of lepers
and that made an impression on a lot of
people they said well there must be
something in this lady's life that she
gave up everything else to experience
this the funny thing was turned out that
the retro diaries she wasn't actually
experiencing that she said she felt
there and almost 50 years she was
working she did it anyways that's that's
probably a good place to stop I mean
Thomas is taking us to this notion
happiness has to somehow include a guy
once you put God in the picture it's
sort of like you know bringing the
elephant to the room it's bigger than
everything else but we have to think
about what would God what would being
happy and God actually looked like you
know what it was for Thomas studying
stuff writing books and you know for
UMass he was a priest what would it be
for other people would it be something
different in our culture see all of you
one day